foreign
let's go out to El Dorado Hills
California and talk to Melanie what's up
Melanie hi Dr John how are you doing
good what's up
good good
um well I'm calling I had a question and
um just like your input on it so how do
I my question is basically how do I let
um the fear of losing someone in the
future
um
um affect how I live with them now like
I'm scared of losing my husband in the
and it comes from past trauma that I've
had and honestly it's affecting like how
I live now and I'm just tired of living
like that you know
and like he's not sick he's not he
doesn't have anything that's like now
um like that's gonna happen but it's
just like this fear that I've had past
losses in my life and I just don't know
I have panic attacks happen every every
so often from different triggers and
um I freak out and sometimes I eat don't
eat for a few weeks I just like lose
weight and and and just freak out so I I
don't know how to how to stop that
affecting and that's definitely taken a
toll on my husband and
um
I just I just want to be better
um
I'm sorry because I've been you
and I've also watched my wife and in
your case her husband
try to
be better on my account when I'm so
anxious that I'm I'm like being married
to a laser right
and it's tough and then my brain spins
out and Spins out and Spins out and
Spins out so here's the hard hard truth
okay
yeah you are going to lose them someday
either you'll pass away or he'll pass
away that will happen at some point in
your life
it's a great um Dr yallum says that
anxiety stemmed from an existential
knowledge that we all have term limits
on this thing we call life
and so the reality is
this has nothing to do with his death
his potential death his this could this
could go at any moment death
um what does he do for a living
uh well right now he works a state job
but he's actually wanting to go into
federal law enforcement so that's
triggered like yeah another of course
yes yeah my mom told me when I was a kid
because of course my dad was a policeman
I want to go be a policeman and then I
want to be an FBI um she sat me down and
said I'm asking you is your mom don't do
that
because I haven't slept in 48 and not 40
in 28 years I'm slept because every time
your dad goes on night shift I don't
sleep and every time right so I get that
totally totally get that
this has to do with you not him
and for a long long time
worrying has served a protective it's
been like an insulation like an
insulator it's it's been a a an illusion
that has kept you safe so you so you
believe
your body's determined that worry helps
out
and what we have to do is be willing to
give up our addiction our habit of
ruminating
we have to give up our addiction and our
habit of worrying we have to give up our
addiction and habit of predicting the
worst possible outcome and then living
in the present as though it's already
here
in lieu of some healthier behaviors and
it's hard because it's going to feel
like you're heading into battle without
a shield for a while
are you interested in that or no
yeah who have you lost
I when I was 14 I lost my my cousin in a
tragic like ocean accident and we
couldn't find his body for a month and
that whole month I had he I had just
recently started bonding with him he was
one of my like closest Cousins and he
was literally the glue in our in our
family and he was only 21 years old and
and they lost him at Sea and couldn't
find him and at that that time it when I
heard that I was shocked I remember
coming into running into my room after
volleyball practice and crying and my
body was just like I cannot handle this
and I feel like every time something
that like triggers I I thought once a
couple weeks ago I saw an Instagram post
of another woman losing her husband and
crying on Instagram it's like that
triggered my anxiety I deleted my social
media accounts I'm like I don't want to
see that anymore but um
so when's the last time when's the last
time you sat down and wrote that cousin
a letter tell him you miss him
your body's just put a GPS pin in that
hey hey Melanie when you love somebody
they die
and that 14 year old little girl
absorbed all the tension in the house
all the fear all the concern all the
searching all of the late nights all of
this getting the news
and now that's your body just is Guided
by that
and yes you said the perfect word it's
scary healing from anxiety because it
feels like it's helping out
feels like you're choosing to go into a
boxing match with only one glove like
with one hand tied behind your back
here's the the reality the reality is
you're going to lose your husband at
some point
the reality is you're going to lose
other people in your life that you love
no matter how tight you grab that
steering wheel that's still gonna happen
so the goal isn't how do I mitigate
every variable for the rest of my life
and the variables everybody else's life
all around me
question is how do I drive with my hands
on the wheel a lot looser that's
building an unanxious life
and that's you saying I want to heal
how do I how do I do that if I have no
control over the feature no control over
anything how do I live you have control
over two things your thoughts and your
actions that's it that's it
and that's a powerless feeling and it
should be a very empowering feeling
because you spent your whole life trying
to control things that you can't control
it's exhausting right
yeah
and it burns out the people who love you
I would start
by writing my cousin a letter tell him I
miss him
I miss you
here's all the things that have happened
since you've been gone
and now I'm married and you weren't at
the wedding kind of pissed actually
hmm
I got a little kid you you would have
been an uncle
or I hope to have a kid one day and
you're gonna be an uncle one day
but at some point you gotta let him go
and your 14 year old self is still
trying to run the show
and then you gotta go see a counselor
for probably the first time
yeah you're gonna have to learn
your body's gonna have to learn new ways
of responding to anxious moments
right now goes to war
with just a few sessions many many
people are able to
oh here it comes in a smile and they
don't judge their body they're just
curious about it what are you trying to
protect me from now oh
husband's put on his uniform to go to
work
he's put on a bulletproof vest which
means he just as a part of his uniform
he's protected himself in case someone
tries to shoot him
I love him I love him
yeah
right
I'm way more like if I just look at data
about police officers about Federal
officers I'm way more worried about your
marriage than I am about him getting
killed
yeah
and as an integral part of your marriage
you being whole and well
it's good right
yeah
how does that sound
that sounds awesome I mean he's an
amazing guy we haven't even been married
a year we've only 10 months of course
he's been the best year of my life you
know he's awesome yeah and so I don't
ever want to lose them enough and it
could be like any day like I hear people
have like one year into marriage but
it's like that terrifies me and it's
just like but Melanie Melanie it
probably isn't gonna happen
yeah that's the statement that has
guided my life
it could but it probably won't and so
since it could I make sure
I don't leave my house unless without
saying the words to my wife I love you
because I always want the last words to
be that
mm-hmm I make sure I hug my kids and
tell them I love them every single day
of their life before I leave
if I get on an airplane I leave a note
in case the plane crashes because it
could happen and then I go get on the
plane because it probably won't
see what I'm saying
yeah and I'm a little bit nutty you're a
little bit nutty and here we are now we
get to go live our lives right
so you are never going on shift without
look at me in the eye and tell me that
you love me you're not that's just
you're never going to do that and you
are never uh gonna go get groceries
without coming to kiss me on the
forehead
and telling me that I'm pretty whatever
else you need you want him to say
because you never know
and then go to the store because it's
probably not gonna happen
it's probably not gonna happen
but again all of this is about your
body's learned response to uncertainty
to lack of control to Somebody That You
Love passed away and you have to be
willing to teach your body something new
so let's let your cousin go let's let
him rest
let's let him spend his time with the
angels and on
a loosen your grip on his life
and then let's call a counselor to call
my friends a better help call local
counselor in your area
and let's be real Direct
I'm an anxious person I've been anxious
for a long time and I'm ready to heal
I'm ready to be whole
you my sister Melanie are worth it